one of the world's longest standing
conflicts flared up once again in the
united nations
it was the turn of the president of the
republic of cyprus at the lectern and he
lashed out at turkey's insistence on a
two-state solution in cyprus but i
cannot live
and noticed
the
absurdity of the turkish rhetoric
which lies in their claim
that the efforts for a compromise
have been exhausted
early in the week the turkish president
had addressed the general assembly
we hope that the problems regarding
maritime boundary delimitation will be
resolved within the framework of
international law and good neighborly
relations
these words incense the president of the
republic of cyprus
president erdogan
also spoke of the need
of maintaining good neighborly relations
and i wonder yet again
which country
had invaded
and to date still occupy cyprus
the greek cypriot side insists the
solution lies in one island one
government
the turkish supreme run side envisions
some kind of two-state solution
and insists there can be no negotiation
unless there is recognition of the
turkish entity
but in what could be a subtle shift the
turkish leader in northern cyprus told
al jazeera that at this stage there's no
longer an insistence on formal
recognition through the un
rather a more informal acknowledgement
of the facts on the ground just to
clarify you saying that there doesn't
need to be formal recognition through
the un that you would be prepared to
accept a statement of recognition i'm
saying is that
first of all
to formally negotiate disciples from to
a successful settlement i want
the acceptance or reaffirmation of my
sovereign inequality
and therefore international equal status
the president of the republic of cyprus
and the leader of the self-declared
republic of north cyprus
held talks in april in geneva as in so
many previous rounds they ended in
failure they'll be having lunch with the
secretary general antonio guterres on
monday but all parties are quick to
stipulate that this is an informal event
and in no way signifies a beginning of a
new round of negotiation
cyprus remains divided by a green line
monitored by un forces
and after nearly half a century the line
appears no less permanent mike hannah al
jazeera united nations